Many of us are familiar with static
electricity. It's that spark you feel
when you scrape your feet across a
carpeted floor and you touch a metal
door knob. The electrical potential
between you and that doorork knob is
different. And when you touch the door
knob, that electricity moves to equalize
that potential. Before you touch the
door knob, the electricity was simply
sitting there and waiting. That's why we
refer to this as static electricity.
Everything has some type of electrical
potential and static electricity by
itself is not harmful. It's when that
electrical energy is discharged that
creates problems for computer
components. The silicon that we use
inside of these computers is very
sensitive to static electricity. This
image shows the damage that can be
created by ESD or electrostatic
discharge. This is taken from a scanning
electron microscope and it is 4,300
magnification. You can see the damage
that's done by that discharge. And
that's why we want to avoid having that
happen to our computer components. When
we touch our finger to that metal door
knob, that discharge is approximately
3,500 volts. If you were to look at how
many volts would be required to damage
your computer equipment, it's 100 volts
or less. This is why we want to avoid
having any instance of electrostatic
discharge anywhere near our computer
components.
There are a number of things you can do
to help minimize or even prevent
electrostatic discharge. One is that you
can keep the humidity over 60%. That
much water in the air tends to prevent
those types of discharges from
occurring. But keeping a room at 60%
humidity would be uncomfortable and our
air conditioning systems keep our
temperatures low and remove all of that
water from the air. So to protect our
computer systems and components, we do
something that we refer to as a self
ground. This is when we would touch some
part of the metal chassis of the system
that we're working on. This will
equalize the electrical potential
between ourself and the equipment that
we're working on. And as we begin
working with other components, we won't
have that electrostatic discharge.
Another important best practice when
you're working inside of these systems
is to always unplug the power
connection. Having that power connected
will not have any effect on your ability
to prevent electrostatic discharge. And
unplugging that power source means that
we are preventing any case of electrical
shock. And like me, you've probably seen
diagrams that describe connecting your
electrostatic straps directly to the
electrical ground of a building. Since
it is possible for that electrical
ground to become energized, you should
never connect any part of yourself to a
building's electrical ground. One great
way to avoid these types of
electrostatic discharges is to wear an
anti-static strap. You would put the
strap around your wrist and then you
would connect the other end of the strap
to some metal part of the device that
you're working on. If you're working on
a desk, you might want to put down an
anti-static pad. You would then connect
the pad to the metal part of the device
that you're working on so that you don't
always have to be connected with a strap
around your wrist. And if you're
standing and walking around while
working on these systems, you might want
to put down an anti-static mat to
minimize the instances of electrostatic
discharge. Once you take a component out
of a system or you're transporting these
components from one place to the other,
you might want to put them inside of an
anti-static bag. The bag is specially
designed to minimize cases of
electrostatic discharge, and it's a very
safe way to move components and not have
to worry about any type of static
electrical damage. Here's a technician
that's working on an anti-static pad.
You can see the pad is underneath the
laptop that they're working on. And
they've also connected an anti-static
strap to their wrist just to make sure
that they minimize any instances of
electrostatic discharge. Here's a better
view of this strap. It has a breakaway
snap that's connected to the strap. So,
if you need to walk away, you can easily
disconnect it, walk away from your
system, and when you come back, you
simply reconnect the strap to your
wrist. And once you take the equipment
out of that system, you can put it
inside one of these anti-static bags.
These look like foil bags, but they're
actually designed of a material that
minimizes static electricity.
Even with all these anti-static devices
in place, occasionally you might still
have a small electrostatic discharge.
So, it's always a good idea to never
touch the components directly when
you're working on them. It's always a
good idea to handle these components by
their edges to minimize any potential
for damage. These components should also
be stored in some type of heating,
ventilation, and air conditioning
regulated environment. So, we would
usually keep these somewhere between 50
and 80° F, or if you're outside of the
United States, it's between 10 and 27°
C. And these components generally do not
like a lot of water in the air. So, you
want to minimize the amount of humidity
that they're subjected to. Very often
you might throw in one of these silica
gel packs into the anti-static bag where
you're storing these components just to
remove any extra humidity from the air.
And if you have the original box, that
makes a perfect place to store these
components. But if you don't have that
box available, you could also wrap that
anti-static bag and the components
within some type of bubble wrap just to
protect it from the elements.